It's your friendly neighborhood,
PewDiePie here
(Airhorn Noises)
See
I- I put it here now so that you know
I'm doing the sound effects all right
If you hear like a cool sound effect
(My Name Jeff)
Maybe not that one but like, uh
(this is my vegetarian BODY)
you know I'm the one doing that shit I control it all
alright stepping it up in 2017
family-friendly Ferix here how you doing (pretty fucking scared from you)
today we're going to learn more about
just about anything you can always
expand your mind get more knowledge(old memes)
today we got to look at developing psychic powers
(knowledge meme and a sound effect that idfk)
and ear rape
that's right i just made you like the video(did you mean dislike?)
I watched this instructional video
and that's how I learned
and i'm willing to share
(guitar playing)
this is an instrument. Play music by
-o'rily?
itself with practice and training by someone(do we car about music show us the psychic powers i need them)
beautiful music can be heard
Hey I can- Hey, this one can play music by itself
(Hatsune Miku - Vegetable Juice Popipo)
without practice and training
you can only produce sounds
the same is true for your other natural talents
like running, nurturing and using your psychic abilities
(wat?)
like a running nurturing and(is this the kazoo kid video ?)
using your psychic ABILITIES
It's just like running
So basic part of you
-basic
they're already within you
they're as natural to you as breathing
-natural
with practice and training you can also develop
your own special psychic talents to bring
harmony ,beauty ,and success into your life
Well you got none of those
- Hi
- Urgh! No!
just like a coach or music teacher or
guide I'll help you discover your own
natural psychic talents and use them
-can't wait
you use these talents every day without
even thinking, with practice you can
develop and use them anytime and anywhere
(Hey what's up you guys, it's Scarce here)
stop appearing out of randOM places
Hi there it's Pewdiepie (laughs)
there are 8 different types of psychic abilities
in fact you may be using one
or many of your psychic abilities
already in your life
what the fuck is this bitch talking about? I mean-
Wait, she knows? She knows about my psychic abilities?
(Dramatic Music)
That's right!
Other psychic readers can als- can read other people's-
that can feel other people's power. And my
power- psychic- ability must be so strong
that it intersects time from 1996 a VHS tape
My God. My God.
With repetition you'll just get better and you can
practice these exercises every day in
your daily life if you do not get
results right away look and see where
you block yourself where your defenses
or fears are coming in be-
Fuck you -huuhuhuhu
Damn it, she knows about my blockage!
(Dramatic Music)
No!
Damn it! -laugh-
Because if you're blocking yourself with me
on this video you're certainly using
those same blocks in your life.
I'm not blocking you. no no no I'm not blocking
you and that is nothing to do with my
life okay you do not look like my mother.
You don't know me ;_;
this is not a class
your abilities are already there
the results will come
this feels like such a fucking cult, doesn't it?
you know talking all this mumbo jumbo
you already have these powers
There is several entities-
-WOAH! Stop!
In fact, once you practice them, you can do them
without even thinking
and nobody can tell you're doing them ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
kind of like when you fart
situate yourself so that your body's comfortable you can be
-k
sitting or reclining and place
-ok
your hands on an inanimate object
anyone will do the size of a chair or couch or
bed the telephone while you're talking
the desk or table (inaudible)
-You have to hold in an animate object
The steering wheel of your car
in that traffic jam and place your feet on
the floor or the end of the couch or bed
if you're lying down
-yea, okay, and then?
Just let any tensions you might feel move
through your hands into
the inanimate object, and through your feet into the
floor
-ok
the inanimate object, and through your feet into the
floor
Just let it flow. You may feel a tingling or rush of energy.
(Kreygasm)
or you may feel nothing at all in your extremeties
this is not a merger of your psychic
abilities. We're not testing remember?!
We are just exploring
(Xmen Intro Music)
-Knowledge
-about you two, Control my mind
(Xmen Intro Music)
Incredible!
Power
(Xmen Intro Music)
AHH!
No, that didn't work. (._. )
(sigh)
Okay maybe, maybe I
will never have psychic powers.
But there's one thing, I struggled with, my
En tyer
LIFE!
I never been cool at parties
and I bet, I'm not the only one, I bet you
feel the same way. Well I found it I
I found it tape from 1986 that will
(laugh)
that will definitely give us the right answer
let's watch
(Plays IT)
Well, already the intro is extremely cool
I know I'll never be as cool as this
Oh it's for chil... goddamnit
Hey, you. You've gotta watch this
Me?
You won't believe your eyes. Ok, I'm gonna cut
eh, all right
this piece of string
yeah
like so
-okay
all right, okay, we're gonna put it in my
-Alrigh-
-Okay
all right, okay, we're gonna put it in my
hand, bring one end over here one
-yea
end over here. Tug on both ends of course
and (pff) blow on it
But it was never together
-voila!
OHH!
OHHHHHHH! :O
OHHHHH (ear rape)
(playing his invisible 4-D drum set)
Show off! Cool stunts, tricks and gags to amaze
your friends!
FUCK YEAH! :D
A Llama!
...
i mean...
camel!
(lol)
oh my god that's so cool how did they do
that
this set is so fucking fresh dude
(jazz hands)
They got a fucking cow couch with neon lights
they got a balloon
They got a cool dog
with glasses
That coffee table is off the hook- wHAT IS HAPPENING HERE!
as I was saying, this is show off. Show off is
about how to be the life of the party.
you are about to see some of the
funniest, most startling, outrageous, and
cool tricks you've ever seen!
damn this dawg is cool man.
And remember these three rules. Number one, be cool.
-ok
eh
Fuck you. :T
Number two, have fun!
yeah i dun-
I'm not into anrly-
I don't- huh. It's not for me.
Because if you're not having fun, how can you expect
your friends to have a good time?
🤔
I don't know.
And number three, have courage.
Weirwood Washington would be if he hadn't had
the courage to show off and throw that
silver dollar across the river?
Bitch you're in an instructional video, alright
don't- don't get ahead of yourself boy.
What would I be, if I did not have my
incredible string trick?
You need to set this part out before your friends come in.
first to take the- ugh-
(burb)
Wait, he's gonna teach mE?!
THE STRING TRICK?!
now take the middle
of the string, and pull the parts out and
then you twist them like this to
-I do
make him look like ends
Ah! :o
okay..
now, take the actual e-
Oh he cheated! >:o
-put them together so they look like they're
attached-
CHEATING! >:O
(snake was spotted)
NAHHH XO
now you're ready to amaze your
friends.
(...)
You take your scissors..
and you cut horizontally..
(........................................)
like so.
Tie on this.. and...!
blow on it!
(WWIII)
and...
the Big Finish...!
ta-daaa! :D
one two three!
I grab the key to my daddeh's ride...
i tOOK MY GIRL DOWN BY THE RIVER SIDE I'M GOING UP!
upside down i'm going UP!
upside down- DOWN, DOWN, DOWN, DOWN, UPSIDE DOWN!
(dude crashed the car)
HOLY SHIT! :O
THAT'S SO COOL!
so strings is actually just made out of other strings.
who'da thunk (english) it man
That's crazy dawg.
We live in a crazy world-
HEY! (oh wow felix)
THAT LOOKS...
you see this shit? oh my god!
Hey guys! Family-friendly Felix here got a magic
trick for you all you need- I- I mean I have
a string here and uh- as you can see it's
just a string and then here we have the
end of it...ugh...I'm going to cut it here and
uh- I'm gonna cut it here!
and then I'm going to grab it.
And (rub my ass with it)you make sure you pull it and then.. uhh-
(play minecarft)You say something.. uhh-(My Name jeff)
something...ugh...TADAAHHH
TA DAAAAAAAAAAAAAA! :D(something coming from the sealing and saying 1 2 3 and starting the music)
"ONE TWO THREE, I grab the key into my daddy's ride..."
I grab the key to mah daddeh's ride! (hes gonna kick your ass for it)
ehh..(are you having sex or dying ?)
(wtf is he trying to do now)
(is he trying to break his setup or having sex with it )
um lets intrest the viewers besides what pewdiepie is dowing right now
*laughs like a maniac*
ehum!  (MY NAME JEFFFF)
(Your scaring the children Felix)
(and me too)
(Airhorn Sound)
Hey what's up huh? Its ya boi jacksep-
*mlg horn * AYO WHATS UP ITS YOUR bOi, JACKSEP-UGH
(Another Airhorn sound)
EHH
It's DJ KAAHN! (Who the fuck is that)
ITS DJ KHA- AH leghajahfkjk
How's it goi- (lmao he failed so bad looser)
Hey how's it going it's your boy jackspeticeye
HEY HOW'S IT GOING
it's your boy jacksepticeye
Ima kill mysel-
imma kill myself *shoots and mlg horns*
(hes dead play that music umm i forgot what the name of it umm) just play a sad music
IT'S ME *laughs*
It's me huhuh
(Groping  invisible girlfriend)
It was me all along ( i tought it was the my name jeff guy
IT WAS ME, ALL ALONG
(Subtitler : I'm seriously done with adding this song's lyrics. -Limeloey) (Anothe Subtitler Named SuperSnowman3 : okay ill do it ) 1 2 3    i grabbed the key to my daddys car i took my girl  down by the river side im going up (music) upside down  im going up (music) upside down
(Other other Subtitler Named Dan Esp: Just fuck already.)
"ONE, TWO, THREE!"
"I GRAB THE KEY INTO MY DADDY'S RIDE"
"AND TOOK MY GIRL DOWN BY THE RIVER SIDE"
"I'M GOING UP!"
"UPSIDE DOWN,"
"I'M GOING...UP!!"
"upside down..." *fades*
Credits to the three Subtitlers (Limloey,  SuperSnowman3, Dan Esp) My NAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAMEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEE              JJJJJJJJJJJJJJJJJJJJJJJJJJJJJJJJJJJJJJJJJJJJJJJJJJJJJJJJJJJJJEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFf